[Música]
é criatividade tem a ver com se
reinventar
com o olhar as coisas com um olhar
diferente encontrar soluções
é aquela inquietação que dá dentro da
gente que a gente busca por coisas novas
as pessoas que são assim geralmente
viram empreendedoras é o se inventar me
remete à maternidade por mais que pareça
estranho é quando a gente vira mãe a
gente tem que se alimentar os filhos
tornam se prioridade ea partir desse
momento você descobre outras funções que
existem na sua vida e muitas vezes os
quatro meses da licença-maternidade
fazem com que a volta ao trabalho
tradicional seja muito cruel seja muito
doloroso
você precisa trabalhar como se você não
tivesse ficado a noite inteira acordado
amamentando seu bebê
você precisa focar no trabalho ao mesmo
tempo que você se preocupa em alimentar
uma criança com a fralda quem está
cuidando como que está a criança e isso
deixa as mães muito preocupadas e foi o
que aconteceu comigo eu trabalhava numa
empresa e eu comecei a sentir que eu
tava muito ausente para o meu filho os
dias passavam muito rápido
as crianças de repente já estão falando
e andando ea mãe fica assim que horas
que isso aconteceu que eu não via o
tempo passar e um filho já está aqui
grandão
por esse motivo além de falta de apoio
social além de muita falta de vaga em
creche é muitas mães saem do mercado
tradicional e viram empreendedoras
existe uma pesquisa que diz que quando
nasce uma mãe também nasce uma
empreendedora
só que essa mãe não se torna uma
empreendedora porque ela quer ser
o chefe ou porque ela tem uma ideia
genial que ela quer colocar em prática
ela se torna empreendedora porque ela
precisa arregaçar as mangas e colocar à
venda dentro de casa ela precisa vender
de alguma forma foi por causa desse
cenário de mães se tornando
empreendedoras sendo empurrados que a
gente criou mas vingar e uma feira
municipal uma vez a natália marçola que
a nossa fundadora do grupo ela viu que
tinha um monte de amiga dela que era a
mãe que estava expondo na feira e
percebeu que essas mulheres podiam ir
além
mas que faltava algo para elas então
mais do ingá há quatro anos atrás surgiu
com esse intuito de ser uma rede de
apoio que vai dar esse algo a mais que
vai fazer com que as mães se vejam como
empresárias e que consigam ter mais
clientes montar orçamentos muito mais
elaborados que façam com que o
empreendedorismo que foi empurrado seja
mais levada a sério é hoje em dia o mais
gato tem mais ou menos umas 300 mulheres
que participam do grupo como
colaboradoras é e nós somos em 5
administradoras uma delas ou eu a minha
história como ele já começou porque um
dia na talha me viu dando uma palestra e
meu bebê estava chorando
desesperadamente e aí a minha mãe que
estava cuidando dele na palestra eu
falei mãe traz aqui que vão aumentar ele
e aí a natália ficou aí ela me chamou e
é lógico que eu aceito e não tinha como
negar a participar de um grupo de um
grupo tão rico que é uma ginga quando
uma mulher vira mãe ela precisa de apoio
quando uma mulher vira mãe empreendedora
ela precisa de mais apoio ainda e não é
só o apoio é do marido é o apoio social
é o apoio das outras mães no mais lugar
isso que a gente tenta fortalecer
entre as outras a gente trabalha muito
com a noção de sindicar internamente
mamãe faz o serviço com a outra mãe
elas formam parcerias entre elas elas
fazem muito networking
a gente tem palestras gratuitas
mensalmente que é pra elas adquirirem
mais conhecimentos e conseguirem colocar
em prática o negócio delas a gente tem
um workshop anual
a gente faz muita troca de conversa de
conteúdo todos os dias
de maneira online e aí temos tópicos
assim diz fraude e finanças amamentação
e orçamento e marketing digital então é
um grupo que permeia por vários assuntos
relacionados ao empreendedorismo matéria
uma das coisas que é mais forte no mês
ligaen essa relação de parceria e aí
quando uma mãe conhece a outra que passa
pelos mesmas dificuldades que ela que vê
que realmente teve que produzir um
material e entregar no prazo que ela
tinha combinado apesar do filho ter tido
febre no dia anterior
isso faz com que a gente fique mais
empoderada isso poderá a gente vê que a
outra mãe tem sucesso mesmo assim e aí a
nossa dificuldade não é uma dificuldade
tão difícil mais por isso que a rede de
conexões entre as mulheres
empreendedoras principalmente as mães é
tão importante
empreender já é muito solitário
se você for mãe mulher e mãe é mais
solitário ainda então é preciso apoio é
preciso que as mães se reúnam a gente
incentiva demais numa engenharia que a
sociedade
compre das mães mas mais ainda a gente
incentiva que uma mãe compra da outra a
partir do momento que elas se dão as
mãos fica muito melhor é e aí a minha
vivência com isso que eu aprendi
há muito que os meses com a mãe dele a
todo dia é de crescimento pessoal
a gente aprende a gente vê outras
realidades ea gente vê que o
empreendedorismo materno é uma realidade
nova é um enfrentamento ao
empreendedorismo tradicional é uma forma
diferente de ver o sucesso uma forma
diferente uma realidade diferente de
encarar o protagonismo visto com outros
olhos que não o do tradicional o olhar
masculino na coisa
a gente trabalha questões familiares
mesmo ea gente defende que se veja as
mães como empresárias sérias
então a gente tem cursos de verdade
curso mesmo até com certificado pra elas
serem mais poderosas
a idéia é essa que a mulher se sinta
mais poderosa e que apesar de não ter
vaga em creche e apesar de não ter o
apoio do resto da família apesar dela
precisa se dobrar em dez pra organizar o
dia a dia pra atender todas as demandas
de filho de marido de esposa também bem
mais assim
e ela ainda consegue ter uma renda fixa
ela sabe quanto custa o produto dela ela
sabe quantos clientes ela tem isso tudo
é muito importante vir uma empresa de
verdade e isso é um sucesso mesmo que a
empresa de verdade de 500 reais por mês
de lucro é o trabalho dela e ela precisa
ser valorizada por isso é por fim uma
mensagem que eu quero dar pra vocês hoje
é de empreendedorismo materno como uma
realidade muito forte que vai fazer com
que a sociedade tenha uma visão de venda
de negócios que seja mais próximo que
seja mais calorosa o atendimento de uma
mãe que é empreendedora geralmente é
muito personalizado
elas fazem tudo com muito carinho com
muita atenção trabalham um prendedor smo
e com
carinho materno não só pelos filhos mas
pelos produtos
é como se os produtos fossem os nossos
filhos também porque a gente quis
inventar um produto é exatamente para
poder curtir mais os filhos
isso traz muito mais qualidade de vida a
gente consegue separar um horário no dia
para poder ir no médico separar um
horário no dia para produzir localmente
que seja de madrugada ea gente consegue
te momentos que no mercado de trabalho
tradicional não dá porque tem que bater
ponto as oito sair às 18 fazer o mouse
correndo e eu nunca vou conseguir curtir
meu filho ver ele andar por exemplo se
eu tô numa rotina extenuante trabalho
então às vezes é interessante abrir mão
de um salário muito mais alto para poder
ficar em casa e ir para o lado humano da
coisa e para o lado familiar
então o empreendedorismo materno ele tem
disso a gente precisa do apoio do resto
da sociedade precisa ser vista e isso
vai trazer bons frutos para a própria
sociedade
vai ser uma economia mais colaborativa
uma criação com o apego que vai fazer
com que os prós próprios filhos sejam
mais conscientes do seu papel na
sociedade
quando eles são mais conscientes do seu
papel eles têm uma personalidade que vai
fazer com que nosso futuro seja melhor
então a sociedade apóiem as mães
compreenda as mães e as mães comprem
também das mães porque quando a gente se
une a gente consegue ser muito mais
forte a gente consegue ser muito melhor
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]